le paris dakar en deuil thierry stade
vide daniel balavoine et trois autres
personnes sont mortes dans un accident
d'hélicoptère moscou marque le coup
avant la reprise des négociations de
genève
gorbatchev propose un plan de
désarmement nucléaire sur 15 hidalgo dit
oui à bernard tapie pour l'om il n'y a
plus qu'à signer un contrat avec le club
marseillais
madame monsieur bonsoir pour eux ce
devait être la fête l' aventure
mécanique dans le désert mais ce fut en
définitive le bout de la piste de
thierry sabine
daniel balavoine la journaliste nathalie
haut dans un pilote et un technicien
radio sont morts la nuit dernière au
mali leur hélicoptère a percuté une dune
il s'est désintégré le paris-dakar déjà
entachée par de multiples accidents
vient ainsi de tourner au drame
voici tout de suite le reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux qui suivent ce qui
devait être au départ une aventure
pleine de promesses il y avait à bord 10
à vinh jean paul le fur le radio
françois xavier bagnoud
le pilote
daniel balavoine
et nathalie odeur du journal du dimanche
tous les 500 morts voici les dernières
images de thierry sabine aux commandes
de son hélicoptère à sa gauche le pilote
françois xavier bagnoud quatre heures
avant l'accident sabine défendez son
rallye avec harkis qui grandit et vous
grandit vers l'exceptionnel le drame lui
n'étant malheureusement pas exceptionnel
et pour s'essayer de ce possible
surtout qu'en plus elle rallie deux fois
une première fois à cause d'un
alcoolique et pourquoi le souligner ne
pas l'oublier quand même pompiers de
dire ce n'est pas le dakar qui a frappé
mais plutôt la fatalité travers d'un
alcoolique je crois que c'est un mal de
chez doucet
ici on n'a pas brisé ce côté là et le
deuxième devra malheureusement il s'est
déroulé sur l'état de liaison sur du
goudron pour des raisons inconnues
daniel balavoine cette fois il ne
courait pas le paris dakar et s'étaient
joints à l'opération paris du coeur une
distribution de pompes à eau dans le
désert balavoine avait demandé à nos
reporter de ne pas lui faire de
promotion sur cette initiative mais d'en
parler simplement afin que cela soit
utile
nathalie haut dans notre consoeur du
journal du dimanche
c'était son premier rallye paris dakar
ancien élève de thierry sabine à l'efap
elle avait commencé à l'agencé française
de presse nathalie avait 26 ans
le drame a eu lieu hier soir vers 19
heures la nouvelle a été connue que dans
la matinée il s'agit d'un accident
le terrain était très très plat il ya
une très mauvaise visibilité et
l'hélicoptère s'est d'abord posé une
fois et puis il a redécollé en suivant
appelé les phares d'une voiture
seulement bon mais ils ont pas vu qu'à
un certain moment la voiture monte alors
kévin d'une de 30 mètres la première
depuis 150 km et l'hélicoptère mois
s'est crashé bons jeux sont morts sur le
coup
l'hélicoptère a brûlé s'est complètement
disloqué dans la caravane du paris-dakar
effroyablement secoué il semble que l'on
vue de poursuivre leur aide soit la plus
forte
malgré l'abattement du paris dakar le
problème
continuez-vous à mardi marche bien
moi je dois dire que
autant il ya j'étais déçu d'avoir été
d'être hors course
quand il n'a plus le courage de route
continuez finnir se rallie quoi qu'il
arrive sachant que l'accident peut
frapper n'importe qui n'importe quand
voici ce qui est arrivé à l'hélicoptère
d'antenne 2
eux ils s'en sont bien sortis oui nous
essayons actuellement d'établir la
liaison directe avec bamako avec nos
envoyés spéciaux jean-louis qu'elle me
gêne et patrick chêne je les ai vus il
ya un instant dans mon récepteur de
contrôle apparemment le faisceau
n'existent plus donc nous allons
enchaîner sur ce journal les à n'importe
quel moment bien sûr en courant de cette
édition pour intervenir c'est le
souhaitent
parmi les cinq morts il ya donc thierry
sabine
c'était l'âme du paris dakar il avait
créé il ya huit ans suscitant du même
coup les polémiques sur le principe même
de ce rallye des sables amoureux de
l'afrique il était lui-même pilote
chevronné et à l'occasion de se révéler
un homme d'affaires très compétent son
portrait par jean ma mère
le nouvel aventurier c'est l'image que
thierry sabine était parvenu à faire
naître au fil de ses huit années
d'épopée il était devenu pour des
milliers de fanatiques le chantre du
désert il a permis à des milliers
d'entre eux soit de sortir de l'anonymat
soit de vivre l'aventuré de leur vie la
découverte de l'art pic du désert du
risque et du danger peut être aussi de
la démesure amateurs de grands espaces
il avait inventé l'enduro du touquet la
croisière verte et niamey bamako
mais pour avoir failli périr perdu dans
le désert
thierry sabine portait un véritable
amour à l'afrique il était devenu à bord
de son hélicoptère
le berger attentif à ce que rien
n'arrive aux brebis égarées bon
samaritain
il était là aussi lorsqu'il fallait
secourir les blessés des accidentés de
plus en plus nombreux au fil des ans
il est vrai que chaque parcours devenait
de plus en plus difficile c'est fait
pour ça dit il
et en homme responsable il en assume et
tous les risques de la course et la
course elle est superbe elle est
exceptionnel parce que le hal est à
l'image du terrain et je peux dire qu'on
adore ces moments très pénibles
eh bien on vit des très très grand
moment l'aventuré s'est terminée hier
soir entre niamey et gourma rharous ce
thierry sabine a disparu au milieu de ce
qu'il est mais sans doute par dessus
tout le désert oui ce qui est sûr c'est
que thierry sabine ne laissait personne
vraiment personne indifférent dans
l'hélicoptère à ses côtés il y avait
donc daniel balavoine l'un des jeunes
chanteurs les plus attachants de ces
dernières années un garçon généreux qui
suivait cette année le rallye pour
distribuer des pompes d'irrigation dans
une région terriblement touchés par la
sécheresse il avait l'habitude de dire
je m'emporte pour ce qu'ils m'apportent
il est donc mort aujourd'hui dans
l'accident il avait 33 ans et sa
personnalité dépassait largement le
monde du show business
il était animé par deux passions daniel
balavoine laventure le goût de la
rencontre ce qui l'avait conduit à
participer au rallye paris dakar et un
professionnalisme rigoureux grâce auquel
il s'était hissé au premier rang de la
chanson populaire
son secret le punch le travail et un
profond respect de son public et toute
façon le spectacle il faut le servir
c'est tout ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils aient 300 personnes 500 1500 5000
c'est la même en bleu il vaut mieux
partir avec 1000 personnes debout que
3000 à 6 voilà c'est tout donc le but de
l'opération c'est quel que soit le
nombre de personnes qui ont dans la
salle c'est de 2,4 c'est la partie de
boxe
la partie de boxe une expression qui
caractérisait parfaitement ce chanteur
mobilisés par toutes les causes
généreuse dès ses débuts daniel
balavoine s'était présenté à tous et
sans complexe comme quelqu'un qui
prenait parti quelqu'un qui disait
franchement ce qu'il avait sur le coeur
témoin sa présence sur le plateau
d'antenne 2 en 1981 face à lui françois
mitterrand
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse désespère elle est profonde et
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française et moi je pense qu'à
la règle générale en résumant un peu
bien raison ce que je peux lui dire
c'est que le désespoir et mobilisateur
et que lorsqu'il devient mobilisateur il
est dangereux et que ça entraîne le
terrorisme
la bande à baader et des choses comme ça
et ça il faut que les grandes personnes
qui dirigent le monde soit prévenu que
les jeunes vont finir par virer du
mauvais côté parce qu'ils n'auront plus
d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir laissé
parler
en passant
france
la peur
c'est parce qu'il désirait contribué à
rendre moins dure cette misère du monde
qu'il chantait que daniel balavoine et
est parti cette fois ci en afrique plus
à côté que dans le paris dakar 1986 il
est mort à deux pas des villages de la
soif et du désert auquel et voulait
transfusé son appétit de vivre et de
partager
voilà j'ajoute que ce soir un hommage
sera rendu au chanteur dans le grand
échiquier de jacques chancel dont
l'invité et julien clerc qui connaissait
bien justement daniel balavoine
je vois que nous sommes maintenant en
liaison directe j'espère que tout marche
bien où sont liées à l'image avec nos
envoyés spéciaux sur le rallye donc
patrick chêne jean-luc calmejane et
j'imagine que c'est la consternation ce
soir dans la caravane
oui oui tout à fait c'est la
consternation ici et le rallye n'est pas
encore arrivé à bamako il ne saurait
tarder les concurrents arrivent en qu'on
voit ici et patrick vers droit qui prend
le relais de thierry sabine est en train
de tenir une conférence de presse pour
savoir si le rallye va continuer dans
quel de quelle manière il va continuer
ce que je vous propose tout de suite
c'est un document recueillis par pierre
lambert hier soir dans l'avion que qui
menait les gens certaines personnes vers
gao
il y avait dans cet avion daniel
balavoine écoutez le il nous disait ce
qu'il pensait du paris-dakar de cette
année
enfin après
m
d'abord ne voit pas non plus moi je
m'aperçois pourtant sur un écran mais
apparemment il ya un petit problème de
liaison avec vous jean-louis on va
reprendre comme nos discussions
moi j'aimerais poser une question
pescarolo et près de vous j'ai
l'impression que c'est bien lui qui est
à côté de vous c'est cela saori pas ce
carolo qui est prête vous jouer très mal
si c'est bien passé sur paris ce qui
n'est pas certain bon à nos côtés henri
pescarolo dont quand ils passent carolos
qui peut témoigner ici plusieurs titres
d'abord en tant qu ami thierry sabine et
des disparus d'aujourd'hui et puis en
tant que pilote mais également en tant
que pilote d'hélicoptère
alors tout d'abord la réaction de la vie
et du pilote de rallye comme tous les
participants du rallye bon moi je
l'abandonné un poteau cette année
puisque j'ai cassé dans la première
étape
effectivement on était devenus tous très
très lié à thierry sabine il nous
emmenait dans des aventures absolument
extraordinaire on choisissait tous
librement de partir avec lui on lui
faisait une confiance absolue et au fur
et à mesure qu'on découvrait ce
personnage on ne pouvait que tomber
amoureux de lui tellement il a eu envie
de nous entraîner dans ses aventures
gigantesque est formidable et on sait
une perte
1 comment sera pour nous aurait la
question qu'on doit poser et qu'on se
pose tous ici est-ce qu'il est bien des
sens est ce qu'il est normal bien qu'on
dise toujours que la course doit
continuer de raisonner en termes de
seconde deux minutes de parler des
concurrents après ce qui s'est passé
vous en tant que concurrent vous
souhaiteriez que la course reprennent
vous savez c'est une situation qui
arrive souvent dans des équipes de
course quand accès un accident se
termine mal qu'il y à un mort dans une
équipe de course il y a souvent eu les
deux réactions possibles sur le
directeur de l'écurie arrête tout soit
au contraire en souvenir de celui qui
vient de disparaître il décide de
continuer je crois que en l'occurrence
en tant que concurrent du paris dakar et
connaissant dont si bien thierry sabine
je crois que lui aurait aimé continuer
je pense que si patrick verdoie décident
ce soir de continuer le rallye c'est
effectivement parce que au fond de
lui-même il doit penser que tirer mais
qu'on continue une dernière réaction
brièvement riz celle du pilote
d'hélicoptère puisque vous avez amené
vous même l'hélicoptère d'antenne 2 qui
est derrière nous de paris alors les
conditions de vol des pilotes
d'hélicoptère sur le paris-dakar sont
tout de même un peu spéciale avec jacky
jaillet effectivement nous venons de
convoyer votre hélicoptère de rechange
on vient de voler pendant 22 heures et
nuit depuis paris pour vous l'ayez
attend donc on est très concerné tous
les deux elle et moi en particulier en
ce qui concerne ce qui peut arriver un
hélicoptère
le pilote de l'hélicoptère de thierry
sabine était en france certainement l'un
des meilleurs pilotes la machine
l'écureuil est un maître complètement
hors de question c'est un appareil avec
sa ordinairement fiable donc
effectivement en course avec thierry
sabine on peut être amené quelques fois
comme en course
s'approcher un petit peu plus près des
limites et c'est peut-être ce qui s'est
passé dans le calme et jeune mercy faux
arif arrêter là je crois que la vraie
question maintenant que les faudra
répondre c'est le rallye va-t-il
continuer je pense qu'on sera un peu
plus tard dans la soirée
rendez vous toute façon dans notre
dernier journal pour avoir donc des
nouvelles rallye ou plus rayon sera donc
tout à l'heure nous avons beaucoup parlé
des vedettes il y avait aussi trois
autres personnes à bord de l'hélicoptère
qui s'est écrasé au mali il ne faut pas
les oublier
la journaliste nathalie houdan qui était
envoyé par le journal du dimanche le
pilote françois xavier bagnoud les
techniciens radio jean paul le fur voilà
ce que l'on pouvait dire ce soir sur
cette catastrophe
la suite de l'information maintenant
avec d'abord les propositions de moscou
à la veille de la reprise des
négociations de genève
c'est demain en effet que américains
soviétiques se retrouvent pour discuter
des armements nucléaires aujourd'hui le
chef du kremlin
mais ce gorbatchev a voulu marquer le
coup en proposant un nouveau plan sur 15
ans un plan destiné selon lui à éliminer
toutes les armes nucléaires
georges bortoli le journal télévisé
soviétique s'est ouvert il ya une heure
par une déclaration de monsieur
gorbatchev lu par le présentateur du
journal
chez koba shafi propose effectivement un
plan pour l'élimination totale des armes
nucléaires d'ici lampes de mick comme
première étape
monsieur gorbatchev reprend sa
proposition de réduire de 50% les armes
nucléaires stratégiques américaines
soviétique dans la même période de cinq
à huit ans il propose de réduire
également le nombre désormais cibler la
deuxième étape commencerait en 1990 avec
un jeune général et une réduction
accélérée de tous les armements est
unique restant et enfin la troisième
étape à partir de 95 conduirait à la
liquidation totale des armes nucléaires
et pour montrer en outre sa bonne
volonté l'urss proche d'eux trois mois
la période dans laquelle elle ne
procédera pas à des explosions
nucléaires
mais tout ça tout ça bien
n'est valable que si les états unis
renoncent à leur regard des étoiles
alors qu'est ce qu'il se passe monsieur
reggane dit je propose d'éliminer la
peur nucléaire en installant mon
bouclier spatial non l'espace mon
bouclier pour empêcher les fusils
nucléaire de passer et implicitement
monsieur gorbatchev lui répond mais
votre bouclier spatial c'est tout à fait
inutile
il suffit ces fusées nucléaire il suffit
que nous nous entendions pour les
supprimer
commençons à nous entendre tout de suite
ça sera beaucoup plus facile et ça
coûtera moins cher donc la balle est
dans le camp de monsieur reggane
maintenant c'est à lui de répondre dans
les négociations à ce niveau vous le
savez tous comptent chaque détail a son
importance notamment l'état de santé des
dirigeants américains ou soviétique
d'où l'intérêt qu'il faut porter à cette
information selon laquelle le président
américain régal sera soumis vendredi un
examen du côlon par le d'examen de
routine à washington après l'opération
qui avait subi monsieur reagan c'était
au mois de juillet dernier
les grandes manoeuvres est ouest ne se
déroule pas tout à genève témoin la
visite au japon du ministre soviétique
des affaires étrangères monsieur
chevardnadzé c'est la première visite au
japon d'un chef de la diplomatie
soviétique depuis dix ans monsieur
cheikh naji en a profité pour mettre en
garde tout you contre une quelconque
participation à la guerre des étoiles
américaines le liban maintenant avec les
combats qui se produisent entre
chrétiens malgré le cessez-le-feu à
l'origine des affrontements l'opposition
entre factions favorable au plan de paix
est tirée par la syrie et les amis
d'aminé gemayel qui sont eux opposés
il faut dire que la position de monsieur
gemayel et bien délicate puisqu'il ne
peut accepter le camp syriens sans
pouvoir ne plus faire valoir son avis
lorsqu'il est à beyrouth en son pays les
explications de pierre serra
voilà pourquoi à minsk bayel ne peut ni
refusé à damas ni accepter à beyrouth
l'accord de paix signé le 28 décembre
dernier entre les forces chrétiennes et
les milices plus humain depuis trois
jours les chrétiens s'entretuent dans
leur enclave de beyrouth et dans la
banlieue nord de la capitale
d'un côté ceux qui ont signé à damas et
qui n'ont pas réussi à imposer sur le
terrain la corde fait qui implique la
fin de la prédominance chrétienne de
l'autre ceux qui sont attachés au
système actuel sans pour autant faire
confiance au président en exercice
amine chbani elle plus de 100 personnes
ont été tuées et il ya au moins 300
blessés en se battant entre eux les
chrétiens prennent le risque d'accélérer
leur élimination tout au moins
politiques
ce soir un cessez le feu est intervenu
mais pour combien de temps voilà il perd
toute dernière minute cette dépêche qui
m'arrive qui est datée de bamako donc du
mali selon laquelle le rallye continuent
leur rallye paris dakar continue bien
donc malgré la catastrophe de
l'hélicoptère dans lequel sont morts
donc cinq personnes dont daniel
balavoine et thierry sabine
ces décisions ont été prises en hommage
à thierry sabine a précisé lors d'une
conférence de presse patrick verdoie qui
donc l'un des adjoints de thierry sabine
dans ce soir on peut vous dire le paris
dakar continue malgré donc cette
catastrophe donc on a maintenant le
cours normal de ce journal puisque c'est
demain que le ministre l'éducation
monsieur chevènement présentera son
projet de calendrier scolaire devant le
conseil supérieur de l'éducation
nationale ce sera un calendrier ni
chèvre mi chou il devrait trancher avec
ce que nous connaissons aujourd'hui sans
avoir pour autant toute l'ambition que
souhaitait le ministre lorsqu'il avait
évoqué le rythme cette semaine d'école
de semaine de congé
à propos des cols les enfants de la
cathode de son talonneur après une année
d'informatique à l'école justement pour
fêter cet anniversaire jean pierre
chevènement avait organisé deux journées
bilan tout à fait officielle mais nous
avons préféré marquer cet anniversaire à
notre façon en allant voir sur le
terrain dans un village comment les
écoliers et leurs professeurs ont vécu
ce difficile passage à l'informatique
puisque 120 milles micro ordinateurs ont
été dispersées dans toutes les écoles de
france depuis hannah le reportage
d'estelle denis
on va retourner les tables de façon à
pouvoir travailler un peu avec
l'ordinateur
l'ordinateur est arrivé en septembre
bouleversant les habitudes de travail
dans l'unique école primaire du village
il y a tout de suite trouvé sa place
chez les plus grands mais ici pour
l'instant on en est encore au stade de
la découverte
pas question d'apprendre à programmer
l'ordinateur il sert surtout à casser la
routine des leçons tu préfère travailler
avec l'ordinateur ou avec le maître
quand il fait le court avec essaye de
m'expliquer pourquoi pas ce qu'on tape
sur un clavier et au tableau pour écrire
avec le crains tu préfères le clavier je
trouve que c'est un jeu c'est du travail
accompli les enfants apprécient beaucoup
les aime beaucoup ça les distraits ils
prennent l'enseignement comme j'ai
plutôt comment pensent âme ce qui est
très bien enfin s'il est évident qu
apprendre l'informatique c'est autre
chose
pour en savoir un peu plus une fois par
semaine monsieur les jours on en aime
ses élèves à écueil est la seule école
du canton à disposer d'un réseau de 6
ordinateurs
l'atelier informatique est animé par le
seul enseignant des environs qui a reçu
une formation six jours de stage bagages
peut être un peu léger pour former les
autres pour enseigner peut il faut que
tu as beaucoup c'est vrai pour
l'informatique sont pour le reste on
aura besoin de stage
vers formant qui vous permettront de
mieux
maîtriser l'informatique les appareils
qui pendant lesquelles les enfants
travaillent l'ambition du plan
informatique pour tous c'est aussi
d'initier les parents avec l'intention
peut-être d'y trouver une autre
clientèle chic c'est une très bonne
chose même dans une agriculture que
c'est une bonne chose si on avait le
temps de te l'apprendre quoi un an après
le lancement de ce projet par le
gouvernement il est encore trop tôt pour
faire un bilan
une chose est sûre l'ordinateur est
entré à l'école
l'ordinateur oui mais peut-être pas
toujours l'informatique en politique
quelques petites phrases de campagne de
campagne électorale la première répond à
valéry giscard d'estaing qui s'est
prononcé sans détour hier pour la
cohabitation au cours d'une conférence
de presse
réponse aujourd'hui d' approche de
raymond barre edmond alphandéry dans
notre journal de 12h45
il faut tout faire dit il pour éviter
cette cohabitation jacques chirac en
revanche se déplacent d'accord avec
l'analyse politique de monsieur giscard
d'estaing échanges vinaigrée à gauche
également il ya 48 heures lionel jospin
engageait les français à voter utile
c'est-à-dire pour le parti socialiste et
non pas pour le parti communiste réponse
de paul laurent pour le pcf jospin ne
peut se faire aucune illusion sur le
soutien des communistes au parti
socialiste
après 1986 enfin à ce sondage bv à paris
match publié cette semaine il nous
montre que la gauche gagne 3 points dans
les intentions de vote pour les
législatives avec que 41%
l'opposition demeure de son côté stable
avec 57 % de ces mêmes intentions de
vote tout autre chose maintenant on
appelle ça la pizza connection une
évocation trop poli pour être honnête de
ce qui est en définitive un vilain
trafic de drogue et bien les pizzas ont
pris un coup de chaud avec un très beau
coup de filet à marseille aux états unis
et en sicile dans les trois pays en même
temps 19 arrestations total dont 7 7
pour marseille seulement sur place
thierry calmette gros bonnets et père
tranquille financier du trafic de
l'héroïne
on a pu les voir pour la première fois
cet après-midi serré de près par les uns
vecteur de la brigade des stupéfiants
menottes aux poignets cet homme pour la
plupart d'origine sicilienne ils ont
tous dépassé la cinquantaine leurs
correspondants américains italiens ont
aussi été arrêtés hier soir à new york
et en italie en tout 19 personnes à
marseille la famille piazza semble être
au centre du trafic
mariano piazza serait à la fois passeur
et financier dans la filière franco
sicilienne propriétaire de restaurant
connu piazza a de qui tenir
il ya 25 ans on perd pied trop restera
perd lui aussi avait été arrêtée porter
de 30 kilos d'héroïne pure
la police a attendu deux ans après la
découverte à miami d'une valise
d'héroïne puis de 75000 dollars à new
york
destiné à des commanditaires marseillais
qui a déjà eu le tort de fréquenter paul
mondolot ni soupçonnait d'être le
parrain des parrains abattu le 29
juillet dernier les policiers l'ont
suivi patiemment deux ans de filature
minutieuse à l'issue de la garde à vue
de cet homme on connaîtra peut-être les
autres maillons de ce qu'on appelle la
pizza connection il n'y aura pas de
retraite dorée pour les pères
tranquilles
il risque plus de 15 ans de prison
bernard tapie avait mis une condition
pour s'intéresser à l'om le club de
football de marseille c'était la
présence à ses côtés de michel hidalgo
l'homme qui a su mener les tricolores à
la victoire est bien la première phase
est réussie michel hidalgo a dit oui à
tapis il reste maintenant à discuter
avec la municipalité de marseille mais
ils d'algos reste néanmoins directeur
technique national au moins jusqu'à
mexico
il en est expliqué avec olivier rey j'ai
décidé de dire oui à bernard tapie est
donc peut-être à l'om
oui à bernard tapie car au cours de mon
travail de réflexion j'ai pu constater
que nous avions beaucoup de conception
commune sur l'innovation les relations
avec les hommes
le sens des défis les objectifs et les
moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour réussir
ce projet qui requiert à la fois
prudents si rigueur sorti aujourd'hui
sur les écrans parisiens de soleil de
nuit c'est un film de taylor hackford
auquel on doit déjà notamment officier
et gentleman c'est un film tout à fait
intéressant d'abord parce qu'il est tout
à la fois question de danse d'amour et
de politique mais aussi parce que
certaines prises de vues ont été prises
clandestinement
or
si où se déroule l'action et plus
précisément mbia leningrad où les
interprètes sont allés avant le film et
en qualité de touriste un seul n'a pas
fait le voyage
michail baryshnikov qui a choisi de
passer à l'ouest c'était en 1974 france
roche
soleil de nuit c'est celui qui règne sur
leningrad ou un danseur russe dissidents
et à l'américain partie à l'est sur un
coup de tête et c'est ensemble de
revenir vers l'ouest
le héros du film à danseur est déjà
parti depuis des années mais l'avion qui
l'emmène en tournée au japon fait un
atterrissage forcé en urss il est arrêté
il va il baryshnikov qui joue ce danseur
a retrouvé en tournant les émotions
qu'il avait éprouvé il ya neuf ans quand
il quitta la russie pour devenir une
star en a mais je suis décidée en un
quart de seconde
j'ai pris conscience que je ne pouvais
plus supporter 126 en fallait que
j'aille ailleurs je bouge
l'ex-pensionnaire du kirov dans le film
mêle la danse classique à la danse
moderne sur fond de disco avec grégory
heinz champion des claquettes
le personnage qu'il joue dans le film
est très proche du siècle dans la vie du
roi par grégory joue le rôle d'un
danseur noir américain qui n'a pas eu de
succès chasseurs et qui a très mal
acceptée le militarisme c'est le racisme
américains et les discriminations
économiques imposées chez nous en noir
j'ai voulu explorer la dissidence de
deux points de vue différents soleil de
nuit c'est aussi une histoire d'amour si
baryshnikov interprète un personnage qui
lui ressemble
isabella rossellini la fille d'ingrid
bergman joue une femme bien éloigné de
ce qu'elle est isabella et le mannequin
le plus payé du monde et dans le film
elle joue une russe modeste et mal
fagotée depuis soleil de nuit elle a
décidé de changer de carrière je vais
devenir une actrice maintenant est une
bonne actrice
ce travail n'est qu'un début j'espère
que c'est un bon début mais je ferai
mieux
avant d'en arriver à la météo avec
bougies de moneta voici les pronostics
du quartier qui se court demain à cagnes
sur mer il y a dix huit partants voici
les pronostics de pierrette brès 15 8 12
14 5 et 13 15 8 12 14 5 et 13
et puis maintenant la météo en compagnie
de brigitte sy monette a très légèrement
différent pour demain demain ce sera
gris et chuchotements chuchotements
parce que les vents vont enfin tombée
très légèrement il faudra encore s'en
méfier à part ça et à part ça il y aura
un peu de tout regarder la carte de
prévisions pour demain
qu'est ce que nous montre cette carte
que nous allons voir tout de suite des
exercices éclaircies qui seront très
belle pratiquement partout mais les
nuages resteront encore nombreux et ses
nuages donneront des averses de pluie
jusqu'à 300 mètres au delà de 300 mètres
sur le morvan sur les vosges le jura les
alpes et sur les pyrénées attention il y
aura des averses cette fois de neige
enfin sur le littoral méditerranéen et
la corse persistance du beau temps toute
la journée
côté températures c'est la baisse très
nette et ce sera pas fini de 2 à 7
degrés sur la moitié nord et de 2 à 11
degrés sur la moitié sud demain demain
jeudi 16 janvier le soleil se lèvera à
8h40 se couchera 17h21 et nous fêterons
les marcels voilà le dernier journal
vous sera présentée par bernard pradines
aux environs de 23h enfin il reviendra
donc sur la décision des concurrents du
paris-dakar de continuer il continue
donc le rallye malgré la catastrophe
d'hier soir avant de nous quitter un
coup de chapeau à daniel balavoine qui
s'est donc tué la nuit passée en
compagnie de thierry sabine et trois
autres personnes dans cet accident
d'hélicoptère
il venait de sortir un nouvel album avec
une bien jolie chanson qui a pour titre
l'aziza daniel balavoine dont la
disparition serait évoquée dans quelques
instants au cours du grand échiquier de
jacques chancel
bonsoir admirateurs daniel balavoine
la ville
non
là
quoi